[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture
aujourd'hui nous sommes à la salle du
jeu de paume à versailles lieux
emblématiques de l'histoire de france
qui vient tout juste d'être entièrement
restaurée voici le sommaire
la salle du jeu de paume a rouvert ses
portes aux visiteurs vendredi 1er avril
à versailles après une restauration de
neuf mois ce lieu emblématique de la
révolution française a retrouvé toute sa
splendeur le parc france miniature à
elancourt a rouvert ses portes samedi 9
avril pour la saison cette année un
nouvel espace de jeu va être inaugurée
et enfin quoi nous dévoile son premier
album ma galaxy le chanteur de jouy en
josas propose treize titres aux
sonorités hip hop ou encore reggae
je me trouve dans la salle du jeu de
paume à versailles
non loin du château ce lieu emblématique
de la révolution française vient d'être
restauré et a rouvert ses portes au
public le 1er avril frédéric lacaille
bonjour jour vous êtes le conservateur
peinture et arts graphiques du château
de versailles alors cela fait neuf mois
que cette salle a retrouvé son éclat est
ce que vous êtes content du résultat
très content du résultat oui parce que
c'est une salle qui n'avait pas été
restaurée à fond depuis sa création en
fait depuis son réaménagement dix ans
dans les années 1880 et là y'a eu pour
la première fois une belle restauration
assez fondamental donc il ya rendu à la
salle tout son éclat de l'époque où on a
créé ici un musée de la révolution
autrefois alors ce lieu était une salle
où l'on pratiqué le jeu de paume 1
l'ancêtre du tennis la dernière fois que
la salle vous l'avez dire que de la
salle du jeu de paume avait été rénové
dès lors du dernier bicentenaire de la
révolution en 1989
aujourd'hui concrètement quels sont les
différents chantiers que vous avez mené
il ya eu surtout une restauration
bâtiment importante parce qu'on est dans
un quartier un peu bad versailles en
contrebas du château dans le quartier
saint louis qui est un quartier assez
humide qui a été construit un peu sur
des terrains à sécher au fil du temps
l'époque de louis xiv est en fait le
terrain reste foncièrement humide donc
ces sont des lieux qui ont besoin
vraiment de travaux régulièrement pour
parvenir à assécher un peu les
structures du bâtiment donc il ya eu de
gros travaux sur les murs sur les mules
toutes les parties menuiserie sert les
fenêtres convoi parti autres le plafond
la charpente et puis on la restaurer
aussi les éléments décoratifs de la
salle le décor peint qui rappelle
évidemment le serment du jeu de paume le
20 juin 1789 la grande peinture de luc
olivier merson et les bustes qui
permettent d'incarner un peu ce premier
grand événement de la révolution les
salles aussi le sol aussi oui tout à
fait donc on a un sol en fait avec une
espèce de ciment en fait une chape
peintes en noir parce que c'était la
couleur en fait qu'on avait dans les
salles de jeu de paume qui permettait de
mieux voir la balle au bond pour les
joueurs en fait en cours de partie c'est
titien le 20 juin 1789 que les députés
du tiers état se sont réunis lors des
états généraux le serment du jeu de
paume a donc été proclamé dans cette
salle c'est ce serment qui a rendu cette
cet endroit aussi célèbre oui tout à
fait parce que c'était une salle de jeux
une salle de sport un gymnase en quelque
sorte qu'ils n'avaient qui était utilisé
à la fois par les habitants de la ville
mais aussi par les gens de la cour et
les membres de la famille royale est
effectivement le 20 juin 1789 quand les
députés du tiers état veulent se réunir
il se présente en fait à la salle des
menus plaisirs où avaient lieu les
assemblées traditionnellement que le roi
fait fermer à ce moment-là prendre part
à voir d'agitation parce qu'il sent qu'à
une agitation qui monte au sein du tiers
état et donc les députés il se trouve
devant les portes closes donc ils font
le tour de la ville il se présente au
couvent des récollets qui n'est pas très
loin d'ici qui refuse l'accès à leur
église et finalement il trouve la salle
du jeu de paume ouverte donc c'est là
qu'il s'installe il faut imaginer qu'il
ya entre 5 et 600 personnes très agitée
qui s'engouffre dans cet espace qui est
disponible à ce moment il n'y a pas de
joueur en fait et donc ils vont se
réunir et décider de prêter ce fameux
serment qui a donné lieu donc à à une
représentation fameuse de l'événement
sur le droite a on peut voir la
représentation du serment du jeu de
paume réalisée par luc olivier marceau
cette toile a lu une histoire est ce que
vous pouvez un noir a tenté alors en
fait cette toile reproduit et finalement
termine une toile que qu aurait dû
réaliser david pendant la période de la
révolution on lui a commandé un grand
tableau l'année qui a suivi le serment
un peu pour le premier anniversaire du
serment il avait eu l'idée lui même de
ceux de ce tableau et donc il a soufflé
l'idée à l'un des députés qui l'a
représenté dans le tableau dubois crancé
ont ils voulaient qu'on lui commande un
tableau dont ils proposaient qu'il ait
décoré la salle des séances de
l'assemblée nationale en fait à paris et
puis les événements de la révolution
sont arrivés il a travaillé beaucoup à
son projet il n'a pas eu le temps de
réaliser complètement son tableau qui
est resté inachevé et donc en 1883 quand
on transforme cette salle pour en faire
un lieu de mémoire on se dit comment
représenter comment évoquer l'événement
de ce serment est donc on reprend l'idée
de la toile de david et on demande à luc
olivier merson qui est un jeune peintre
qui se lancent dans la dans la peinture
d'histoire de reprendre le travail de
david et de le parachever en quelque
sorte et c'est donc la grande toile
qu'on a ici dans la salle qui réalise
est donc 100 ans après le premier projet
à l'occasion de cette restauration vous
avez créé un podcast justement sur
l'histoire de la toile du serment du jeu
de paume
donc il est à retrouver sur le site du
château de versailles cette peinture at
elle aussi bénéficié d'une d'un
nettoyage oui c'est une peinture qui a
été restauré surtout c'est une toile ce
volet qui a été peinte en atelier par
merson et qui a été ensuite marouflé
dans la salle si la qualité en fait
collée sur le mur d'une manière très
puissante donc on ne peut pas du tout la
décoller de son support le mur était
avec le temps s'était fissuré et donc
les fissures avaient déchiré la toile
donc il ya des fissures importantes
qu'il fallait faire disparaître parce
que pour retrouver une visibilité
complète de la scène et la peinture
était aussi très encrassé donc il ya eu
tout ce travail de nettoyage qui a été
menée par des restauratrices de peinture
pendant quelques mois qui a permis deux
à la fois retrouver la lisibilité en
comblant les fissures et retrouver de la
profondeur pour la composition donc on à
la peinture là aujourd'hui pratiquement
comme elle est sortie de l'atelier de
mer sont elles étaient installées ici
derrière nous on peut voir découvrir la
statue de jean sylvain bailly président
le proviseur de la toute nouvelle
assemblée nationale pourquoi il ya une
statue en pied à son nom dans ce lieu
alors ça c'était parce qu'on s'est dit
comment il fallait incarner et
finalement l'événement et en dehors de
la peinture de merson reproduisant le
tableau david sur lequel sur laquelle
n'avait bailly est très présent
puisqu'il est au centre de la
composition monté sur une table
prononçant le serment que reprennent
tous les députés à l'unisson et en fait
on s'est dit qu'aussi finalement une
statue une oeuvre en trois dimensions
incarnerait encore davantage le
personnage donc on a commandé cette
statue à rené de saint marceau qui est
un des grands sculpteurs de cette époque
là pour avoir voilà le président en
train de prêter le serment qui a
lui-même à lui seul résume en fait tout
le tout la chaleur la ferveur de ce
moment de 1789 le financement des
travaux de restauration a bénéficié du
soutien des élus de l'assemblée
nationale et des mécènes particuliers la
salle du jeu de paume est désormais un
ré ouverte et accessible en visite
guidée merci beaucoup frédéric et à
l'accueil d'avoir été notre invité je
vous en prie merci
[Musique]
le parc france miniature a rouvert ses
portes depuis le 9 avril 25 attractions
et 117 monument en miniature sont à
découvrir une nouveauté 2022 un nouvel
univers pour les aventuriers disponible
dès le 23 avril la tour eiffel le
château de versailles ou encore le mont
saint michel plus de 117 monument en
miniature sont à découvrir ou à
redécouvrir au parc france miniature à
elancourt il a rouvert ses portes le
samedi 9 avril c'est l'occasion de re
découvrir des monuments qu'on a croisés
au cours de sa vie ça rappelle autant
d'émotions qu'il ya eu deux voyages qui
a eu de partage et pour cette année 2022
une nouveauté l'ouverture d'un espace de
jeu koh lanta pour les enfants et les
adultes cette année on a en effet
l'occasion d'ouvrir une nouvelle ère de
jeu qui se veut une zone humide on va
pouvoir s'arroser ou éviter les gouttes
en tout cas puisque on propose à nos
visiteurs de partager les aventures de
koh lanta et à travers des certaines
épreuves du jeu et l'objectif étant pour
chacune des équipes de sortir le moins
mouillé de l'aventuré aura retrouvé
évidemment des marqueurs que sont la
plage l'eau la mer les zones humides
avec la pluie et le beau temps en tout
cas le beau temps pourra difficilement
contrôler ça se fera naturellement tout
cas la pio pour la maîtriser et et
pouvoir s'amuser à s'arroser et ce défi
est donc c'est vraiment pour tous les
âges en plus de cette nouveauté les
visiteurs pourront retrouver 25
attractions et expériences ludiques
adaptées aussi pour les enfants la
billetterie est déjà ouverte déjà des
réservations et puis des billets
prévendus mais qui sont pas datées donc
mais qui courent sur cette période de
d'ouverture entre début avril et la mi
mai donc on aux estimations nous donne à
peu près un démarrage ou autour de 1000
visiteurs jour entre avril et les
vacances de toussaint le parc espère
accueillir environ deux cent cinq mille
visiteurs en attendant à l'occasion du
week-end de pâques france miniature
propose le 16 17 et 18 avril une chasse
aux oeufs et un jeu de piste le groupe
aixois de luxe sera en concert à la
batterie jeudi 21 avril à guyancourt et
l'indre ont présenté leur nouvel album
moustache gracias on en parle avec lille
et boy très bon goût du groupe
[Musique]
de luxe est un groupe qui existe depuis
2007 c'est c5 moustachu kg à la batterie
et beatmaking callas à la base qui sera
emporté quand il avait 6 ans donc c'est
vraiment un groupe de potes avant d'être
un groupe de musique les rencontrer
pierre à la guitare un peu au collège
soit pour s ouvrit le percussionniste et
le vidéaste au lycée et pépé le
saxophoniste multi instrumentiste
supercritique un peu à cette période là
aussi élire je les ai rejoints en 2010
quand il est joué dans les provinces
[Musique]
ont ici c'est qu'on a des boues super
différents en fait est qu'on se prive de
rien dans des morceaux morceaux très
différente de l'un à l'autre mais je
dirais qu'on fait de la musique de scène
[Musique]
les paroles c'est un peu au mal à notre
histoire et est à nous d mon anneau d
mookie qui font que on a la rage de
toujours s'acharner d'aller toujours
plus loin tous les jours ils tous ces
projets toujours plus loin et c'est
cette même chronique parfois qui tamise
et donne envie de se cacher quoi
[Musique]
il ya des parties acoustique du bon
vieux de l'uff qui cartonne et qui fait
danser qui fait j'aime des îles des
moments beaucoup plus intimiste on vous
demande de ne pas tuer et de claquer des
doigts plutôt que de de clapet des vins
on essaie de de toujours faire ce qu'on
a toujours adoré faire pleins
d'interaction avec le public
m'a galaxy c'est le nom du premier album
de l'artiste jova siens au queen's il
est sorti le vendredi 8 avril 13 titres
aux sonorités hip hop reggae ou encore
gospel nous l'avons rencontrée regarder
[Musique]
moi quand j'arrive
koméla bamba koné album fame
un premier album pour ce jeune artiste
qui habite à jouer en josas quan ce
mélange hip hop reggae avec des
sonorités gospel j'ai fait des mixtapes
et là c'est vraiment l'album concret
café que voilà je suis arrivé jusqu'à
jusqu'à là aujourd'hui donc surtout sur
l'est des instrus phase 1 parce que sur
les mixtapes c'était des faces b donc
des instructive appartenait pas donc là
c'est vraiment un produit que j'ai faits
de a à z flocons dans cet album intitulé
ma galaxy ce sont 13 titres qui parlent
de la vie quotidienne d'amour ou encore
de problèmes de société son dernier clip
mon étoile est sorti le même jour que
son album le 8 avril dernier
[Musique]
je me suis mis dans ma bulle pour
raconter un peu ce que je voyais les
ressenti des gens de ce que de ce qu'ils
me disaient entre guillemets et je le
retranscris sur ce morceau autre clip
qui rassemble plus de 11000 vue kimbembe
il a été tourné à fontenay le fleury le
cri pour la tournée à fontenay le fleury
aux copains d'abord et c'était marrant
parce qu'en plus il y avait un concept
vu que là bas il y avait un coiffeur il
y avait un tatoueur une seule une grande
salle terrain c'est tout donc on a joué
un peu de tout ça parce qu'à la base
c'est un restaurant qui a plusieurs
concepts et donc avec les dix artistes
bah en fait tout le monde avait son rôle
à jouer c'était plutôt sympa on se fera
une petite tournée dans la france et en
belgique prochaine date le 7 mai à paris
il s'arrêtera aussi au bar-restaurant
copains d'abord à fontenay le fleury
la deuxième édition de la biennale
d'architecturé et de paysage se tiendra
du 13 mai au 13 juillet à versailles au
programme neuf expositions des débats et
des colloques sur le thème terre et
ville on en parle avec françois de
mazières le maire de versailles et le
commissaire général de l'allier l'aube
sept binômes ciblée elle va analyser à
la fois tout ce qui relève de cette
notion de l'agriculture périurbaine la
préservation du vivant et en même temps
comment on continue à bâtir la ville
comment on la rend plus agréable aussi
plus esthétique et le sujet particulier
de cette biennale 2022 c'est la terre et
c'est la fin de cette fuite culture
merci de nous avoir suivis rendez vous
la semaine prochaine dans un autre lieu
culturel yvelinois bonne soirée sur tv
[Musique]
et
on
e